before we get on to the detail can I
first give an update on the condition of
the Prime Minister I know a lot of
people be concerned about that I can
tell you he's receiving very from the
excellent medical team at Sun Thomas's
hospital
he remains stable overnight he's
receiving standard oxygen treatment and
breathing without any assistance he's
not required any mechanical ventilation
or non-invasive respiratory support he
remains in good spirits and in keeping
with usual clinical practice his
progress continues to be monitored
closely in critical care and will give
further updates on the PM's condition
when there are any material developments
and I know that there's been groundswell
of messages of support from people here
at home from leaders across the world
and I know that everyone will want to
join with me in wishing the Prime
Minister a very swift recovery as you
will know that Prime Minister asked me
to deputize for him whilst he recovers
and in line with the Prime Minister's
instructions this morning I chaired the
meeting of senior ministers tackling
coronavirus and this afternoon I chaired
an update for members of the cabinet I
think it's probably worth just
remembering that as will be the case for
many people up and down the country who
know someone at work who's fallen ill
with the coronavirus it comes as a shock
to all of us he's not just the Prime
Minister for all of us in cabinet he's
not just our boss he's also a colleague
and he's also our friend so all of our
thoughts and prayers are with the Prime
Minister at this time with Kerry and
with his whole family and I'm confident
he'll pull through because if there's
one thing I know about this prime
minister he's a fighter and he'll be
back at the helm leading us through this
crisis in short order and of course for
us in cabinet we know exactly what he
wants from us and what he expects from
us right now
and following the cabinet discussion
today I can reassure the Prime Minister
and we can reassure the public that his
team will not blink and we will not
flinch from the task at hand at this
crucial moment
we'll keep all of our focus and all of
our resolve with calm determination on
delivering the government's plan to
defeat the coronavirus and it's with
that objective and with that unity of
purpose that the Cabinet turned to
business today we had reports from four
ministerial groups on the action we're
taking across all of the strategic
priority areas including NHS capacity
procurement of ventilators and personal
protective equipment the delivery of
public services including Social Care on
the economy and our support for those
businesses and workers and of course on
the international action we're taking to
reinforce our efforts on the home front
as we've explained before our action
plan aims do you slow the spread of the
virus so fewer people need hospital
treatment at any one time and that will
help us protect the NHS is ability to
cope at every step we've been following
the scientific advice the medical advice
and we've been very deliberate in the
actions that we've taken so that we take
the right steps at the right moment in
time we're increasing our NHS capacity
by dramatically expanding the number of
beds key staff life-saving equipment on
the frontline so people have the care
they need when they need it most
as we've consistently said we're
instructing people to stay at home so we
can protect the NHS and so that we can
save lives so today I can report that
through the government's ongoing
monitoring and testing programme that
again as of today two hundred and
thirteen thousand one hundred and
eighty-one people have now been tested
for the coronavirus fifty-five thousand
two hundred and forty two people have
tested positive the number of people
admitted to hospital with coronavirus
symptoms now stands at eighteen thousand
five hundred and eighty nine and of
those who have contracted the virus six
thousand one hundred and fifty-nine have
I'm very sorry to say died every death
in this pandemic is a tragedy in our
thoughts and our prayers or with their
loved ones that what must be an
incredibly difficult time and I think
these figures were in full
that the single most important thing
that we can all of us do right now in
this national effort to defeat the
coronavirus is keep on following the
government's advice